hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in round 2 of
chess that comes Isle of Man
international tournament it's a game
between two Indian Grandmaster civility
with ratty and Debashish does and I'm
sure you're all gonna enjoy it it's
against the fringe defense and it's
really really just a wonderful game and
we haven't had a photo challenge in
quite some time now so I just prepare
one here the challenge is how many
people in this photo can you name so
there you have it it's a it's a photo
from Daniel Rangers a Twitter page so I
will put a link to it in the description
below as well now all of these people
are in some way connected to this
tournament either by organising it or by
commenting on it or by playing in it or
or by you know photographing so pretty
sure you know most of them and one of
them of course
maxime beaugeois grove it is his
birthday so this is a birthday dinner so
there we have it best of luck to
everyone now let's check out this very
nice game but it has the white pieces
and he opens with E for like the title
suggests his opponent responds with each
six we had the French defense d4 d5
Knight to c3 and now capturing on e for
the Rubinstein variation a knight
recaptures now comes the Bishop to d7
ninth to f3 and now Bishop to c6 we have
the Fort Knox variation of the
Rubinstein Bishop to d3 Knight to d7 and
now we did castles we have 90 G to f6
and now although sometimes you want to
perhaps develop a piece and then also
defend day or night that's attack twice
now but here black would simply get too
much out of these exchanges and you
don't want to allow something like this
is white once you defended the b7 pawn
this Knight can come to f6 and always
well for black so it it simply moves the
knight back and I smooth with the knight
back Bishop to e7 and c4 now and what I
really enjoy about white here is that
every move will be a developing move
dust castles we have the brush up to f4
and now comes b6 Queen to e to
developing the Queen also connecting
rooks preparing making some room for
them so they can enter the game as well
and Bishop to b7 seems like a waste of
time this Bishop to b7 move but it's
really not if you continue the game here
can use the fact that the bishop on c6
is undefended you know for for Rhema
nuvaring his pieces here black whatever
had either have to react to this or a
waste time now so by playing Bishop to
b7 early you're actually you know saving
time by wasting time and also you'll see
what White's plan is so then you will
decide how you want to develop your
pieces rook a to D 1 and now comes Luke
to e8 and now Bishop to C to a very nice
move that opens up the D file for the
rook also you are free to create some
batteries here with the Queen and Bishop
at the threat and perhaps dh7 square and
also what White has points the remain
over this Bishop to a4 to threaten this
rook as the knight and d7 will be pinned
now we have Queen to c8 getting the
Queen utter the D file and now also here
we have a nice queen [ __ ] battery that
if this opens up for some reason then
could be dangerous for white Bishop to
a4 as we've already mentioned and now
Bishop to f8 now the rook is controlling
D file we have Knight to e5 and now c6
the night and d7 is no longer pinned and
now we have worked to d3 a very nice
rock lift as white is definitely
planning to bring this bishop back and
with the bishop pair eyeing over the
Kings side perhaps this rook will
somehow make his way over here the Queen
might be able to come to g4 to h5 and
the white could create perhaps a very
nice King side attack here if you
capture for example Knight captures on
e5 d captures this night is coming to d7
and now it can be very dangerous for
black this night is coming to h5 like we
said the deposition on the King side is
no longer defended by black Queen can
come to g4 ro can come to g3 h3 and all
of black's pieces are cramped on the
Queen side not really doing anything to
help out with the defense of the King
side
so after this rook sorry about that
erupt the d3 move a nice rock lift a6
first preparing b5 so rock the c1
now if b5 then this can be played and
the the rook will be controlling the C
file which is very nice
rook to a7 perhaps the rook will now
help out with the defense of the King
side here and also moves like Queen to
a8 are possible
we have a 3 into a 8 and now comes
Knight to e4 we have b5 Bishop to c2 and
now comes c5 now this knight on e4 is
attacked three times by the Bishop of
Queen and the knight and the White has
to react to this Knight to g5 this comes
up with a double attack against the f7
pawn so black doesn't have time to
capture and g2 just yet
so first B captures on c4 with an attack
on the rook and now comes the rook to g3
this comes with defending the G to pawn
and also black still has a lot of
problems here still his f7 pawn is under
attack but you have other problems that
you have to face this bishop is still
controlling h7 the queen is still coming
into the play at some point when this
Knight moves so black first plays g6 a
nice defensive move that opens up the
dark square bishop but it simply doesn't
work here white played Knight captures
on h7 and what's the idea
the idea is that all of White's pieces
are attacking the King side so you
definitely have reasons to do this
Knight characters on h7 and now comes
the Bishop captures on g6 so what do you
do here if you play F captures on g6
then you get the root captures on g6
Bishop to g7 now comes rook captures on
g7 King chapters on g7 and hours for
Queen to g4 check it's all over you
either go back and then you get knife to
f7 which will be checkmate or you can go
perhaps left fate a but again Buster to
h6 check King moves and now Queen to g7
check King moves and now Queen captures
on d7 I will again be checkmate
so after Bishop to g6 displayed Knight
d2 f6 bringing another defender into the
game but this simply doesn't work
White has a beautiful checkmate in 4
here it's a very nice forced variation
although white can win in a lot of
different ways there is one that is
specifically
beautiful so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find that one that
force is made in four moves so I'll give
you a couple of seconds for you to
decide where we want to do it or not
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
sacrificer of the Queen
and for those who just wanna enjoy the
show you can win of course with Bishop
to f7 captures but Queen to h5 is what
was played in the game it is the
quickest way to victory and it was in
this position that the Basha does
decided to resign the game why did he
resign
well first we must ask ourselves the
obvious question what happens if Knight
captures Queen
well if Knight captures Queen then you
get Bishop captures on f7 check it's a
double check
since the check is delivered from the
rook and also from the bishop so white
black has only one move King to h8 and
now comes Rock to g8 and this is now
checkmate but what happens if the queen
is not captured what happens if you try
to for example play Bishop to g7 and
bring another defender into the game
then the idea is Bishop captures on h7
and now it doesn't matter you can either
move the King to f8 and then you get
Queen captures on f7 checkmate or you
can go King to h8 and again you will get
nice captures on f7 a nice checkmate as
the bishop is covering the g8 square and
also after Queen to h5 you can play
something like Bishop 3 for perhaps
bringing another defender into the game
but here black will face a different
Queen sacrifice Queen captures on h7 a
very nice move forcing black to capture
it Knight captures on h7 and now again
you get Bishop captures on f7 this comes
with a double check King has to move and
now again rook the g8 will be checkmate
so hopefully after Knight d2 f6 you all
found Queen to h5 and now you feel very
good about yourself as you're an
excellent Queen sacrificer
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it it's it's a really wonderful
25 move game a nice miniature and of
course in today's today is the world
were you know pretty much everything is
engine lines and a lot of games are
drawn seeing a nice game like this
really really makes you happy that
someone decided to play the French
against a plus 2700 player so now I'd
like to thank Thomas Perry William right
William right out
Eric LaBelle Marc gamble and the James
Crenshaw for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I'll see you
soon perhaps with another game from ion
chess or perhaps even continuing the
Bobby Fischer series with the game 16
Fisher versus passkey thank you all and
I'll see you soon